e aí galera tá todo mundo imitando
milkshake do bob está tem muita
irritação tosca por aí começa a virar
bagunça então estou aqui vou botar ordem
essa joça aqui com a imitação menos pior
o milkshake do bob's eu trouxe aqui o
milkshake do seu xing aqui o seu chip
trouxe também um milkshake do e bonito
e também tem um milkshake novo e de uma
famosa lanchonete é que até aqui
pertinho pela frente conta que o rapaz
com um rapaz
tudo bom nascer e taxa é que o teste
serve taxa segue o seguinte vai vender
ele né ele vai escolher como eu cheguei
ele prefere só lembrando que o teste é
cego não é surdo não tá todo mundo
quietinho na minha gente e beleza onde
ir embora
gostei mais do que a gente fez o teste
com várias outras pessoas
se liga no que deu
vocês o aqua melhor lá vem mais os erros
é mais do b tranqüila de eduardo atua
depois de tanto mil que page quem aqui
que é o sabor de verdade do milk shake
do bob's aqui é pra espanhol é muito
elevada mil chega de batalha moleque
também quer sair eo cheiro do bob's é ou
não é só no blog